[Musica]
devo stare attenta al lupo ma devo anche
trovare tutti gli ingredienti slime
altrimenti il lupo non scomparirà però
devo stare attenta a non essere beccata
dal lupo altrimenti perderà la sua lente
ma ho già trovato il primo ingrediente
non ci credo è stato facilissimo però
ancora non ho visto il lupo
ho paura che mi stia osservando e che
spunti all'improvviso meglio che ci
muoviamo picchia berlino devi aiutarmi
tu sei una sorta di cane lupo vero o
forse no puoi aiutarmi perché sei una
sorta di cane lupo che stai benissimo
marino mi ha indicato la paletta
bravissimo berlino grazie
ora aiutami a trovare tutti gli altri
ingredienti no senza mangiarti gli
alberi hero vostro vigili lupo assieme
bacio andiamo berlino
dobbiamo entrare dentro casa perché non
so se qua fuori si sono ancora
ingredienti
dobbiamo entrare ok
però mi devi aiutare devi stare attento
al lupo mi devi avvisare se vicino ok
[Musica]
ok sono dentro casa abbiamo già
recuperato due ingredienti sono stata
fortunata
non so se il lupo è rimasto fuori o sei
dentro casa noi continuiamo a cercare
gli ingredienti e speriamo che sia fuori
qua non c'è nessun lupo ma neanche
ingredienti mi sembra prima foto questi
tinguely 24 vedere nell'altra stanza
[Musica]
ma il gruppo berlino perché non mi ha
avvisato marino a qualcosa
guardate
[Musica]
come faccio a prenderlo ancora di
spiegarlo che faccio un problema basta
nella vita non c'è niente di strano che
io possa prendere la colla e ne pensi
aiutami e vino mi chiedo aiutare berlino
tv brutti vabbè io provo a prenderla
speriamo bene
[Musica]
marino siamo io posso ha chiuso dentro
questa casetta per gli ingredienti in
mano li ho conosciuti per la cameretta
che strano berlin che stai facendo
marino dobbiamo uscire di qua ho paura
che il lupo
ci abbiamo chiuso quota poi tornare
mangiarci quindi meglio se chance a
porta è chiusa ovviamente vediamo se
questa pre confezionate il lupo ha
dimenticato di chiudere la finestra ma
ciò è fatta finestre più gravi tugliesi
al sito berlino che si ottiene da qua
provaci
io proposi re data proprio dalla
finestra
ci proviamo a berlino proviamo a uscire
fuoriuscire dalla porta è chiusa
come non ad aprire la porta persino
scusa crosti sei bravissimo robertino
sito farmi aiutate migliore berlino
fammi passare perché non vi cui fa rossi
ne so che pericoloso ma devo per forza 5
sta bene io esco spesso anche se non
vuoi che esco io valuti le ok ce
l'abbiamo fatto berlino sono scappati
dalla casetta
ora però è meglio servizio perché non so
al lupo potrebbe essere ovunque quanto
dovesse diventare sono una casetta tra
poco dopo arriverà e mangerà tempo c'è
nella casetta e si parlino più motivati
altri ingredienti altrimenti il gruppo
ferretti mangerà perché ho deciso di
rimanere lì come se berlino stesse
cercando di far pensare che qualcosa per
lì non mi dispiace ma io devo fare
foundry mi dispiace la sortita devo
andare
cercherò di recuperare gli ingredienti
il prima possibile così posso liberarti
anche dai andiamo
al mio via andiamo in quell altra stanza
vediamo se troviamo qualche predetto che
321 via via
lo stesso
[Musica]
all
finora tutto liscio
sono riuscita a recuperare anche la
ciotola quindi ho già dato molto la un
pigmento trasporto l'ho mi manca solo la
colla la soluzione per lenti il
bicarbonato e ho vinto la challenge
spero che siano facili da trovare
vediamo un po cosa ho già visto la colla
che quando il tricolore e il lupo non
c'è quindi sarà semplicissimo a prendere
la corda pronti andiamo
ecco la lingua mentre la cosa viva in
entrano pochissime cose dopo di questa
pagina dieci gli 8 grazie siamo non
momento nella casetta ho preso comunque
la con nella ciotola evviva ce l'abbiamo
quasi fatta
mi aiutato tantissimo grazie
ora ci manca solamente la soluzione
parlantina si tu no
la soluzione per l'ente e bicarbonato di
sodio che non si prende un'altra volta
il lupo ce la possiamo fare
andiamo sbrighiamoci prima che scada il
tempo ti amo o merlino
dobbiamo recuperare gli altri
ingredienti perché notiamo perché lui
vederla dentro io devo andare
[Musica]
ma dove possono essere però qua non mi
sembra che si stia niente per il lupo
era nascosto la dietro quindi mettesse
notato devo controllare se ancora là
dietro non posso rischiare dell'impresa
un'altra volta
[Musica]
questa sera su spazio quello il
bicarbonato e figli fanno trovato più
guardate partiti quindi dovrò per forza
a prenderla a prenderla
[Musica]
sono la nonna sei un solo nuovo ma la
nonna premi hai mangiato trendy
niente non è niente solo una cosa che mi
interessava niente ha aspettato fare i
biscotti per te per il lupo cattivo
buono è il lupo niente ora mi dispiace
ma devo andare
[Musica]
che brutto e perdono un po tenere la
maniglia no un no merlino è rimasto là
fuori
povero berlino ma non ho tempo
mettiamoci si apre una porta e la cura
la ricca prima che gli diamo giu
regalarvi devo sbrigarmi di mettiamo la
colla la colla con la maledizione
l'azienda
ecco fatto perché non essendo palla gol
vorrei detto questo rosso che dovrebbe
essere segmento ecco fatto non so di che
colore diventerà rosso il batterio con
l'argento mischiamo che è uscito un
colore strumento e artista sbrigarmi
devo sbrigarmi ok il carbonato non si è
trovato questa tesi su un bellissimo ha
un colore fantastico
però devo subito a prima porta e sperare
che il gruppo sparisca anche perché ho
lasciato ho lasciato murray nono fuori
non voglio che succeda niente
siete pronti a thiam
[Musica]
il lupo storica con questo zain spero di
aver fatto tutto giusto
quando mi fu entrambe l'inter solo
berlino ti ho fatto niente vero aspetta
aspetta
io vado l'uso ha imbucato mano
[Musica]
se volete vedere un altro video con
cappuccetto rosso e il lupo lasciate un
bel mi piace a 20 mila mi piace fare un
altro video con il lupo e il cappuccetto
rosso e ora vi lasciamo qua 4 caselline
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione
[Musica]